yeah i had never seen her in anything i
tell her this all the time i had not
seen her the uh the only uh film that i
had watched her work in without even
knowing it was this christmas film that
i think was on netflix
but i had not watched parks and recs i
had not seen black bear i'd seen them
all now um i had not seen ingrid goes
west and it's just for the lack of like
the last seven years with kids has just
been you know i watch you know wreck-it
ralph every five minutes so it's like i
know
what i mean ask me about coco i'll tell
you everything but i just didn't know
about the other stuff so
but when i got on the zoom with her and
john
that she was
easily the reason
really
yeah she's a legend she's i i tell her
she's uh i've never seen
it so you know we're in such a weird
time right
650 television shows 950 movies last
year
we don't
like what she's doing is extraordinary
she's hysterical
yet
i can just name three movies that is
some of the best dramatic performances
i've ever seen emily being the best of
them maybe black bear
that's such a rarity i can only name
very few actors phil hoffman comes to
mind and robin williams and people that
do drama and comedy seamlessly
you know and she is doing that there's
just very few and i know of course
everything like yeah but not at that
level of course give her a moment yeah
just you know but it's like when you're
doing that
seamlessly when you're funny
and you're knocking it out apart
dramatically i mean we gotta stop and
pause for a second and say
that's a rarity
yeah there are certain actors that i
absol i love daniel day-lewis but hasn't
made me laugh recently you know what he
hasn't made you laugh ever
well no i actually did find him pretty
funny as bill the butcher he's pretty
funny oh yeah yeah for sure uh what was
that called new york
gangs of new york gangs in new york
you